THE SUPERINTENDENT CALLED IT
OUTSTANDING.
>> Bret: PHIL KEATING LIVE IN
PARKLAND.
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTION MANY AMERICANS ARE
ASKING: WHY ARE THERE SO MANY OF
THESE MASS SHOOTINGS AND WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO PREVENT THEM?
CORRESPONDENT DOUG McKELWAY
REPORTS THAT THE DEBATE GOES
BEYOND GUNS TO THE ACTUAL FABRIC
OF AMERICAN CULTURE, AS THE
KENTUCKY GOVERNOR SAID EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
>> THIS CULTURE OF DEATH IS
BECOMING PERVASIVE.
IF IT'S NOT ADDRESSED BY ALL THE
IMPERFECT PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
WITH A SENSE OF PURPOSE AND A
SENSE OF ASPIRATION, I THINK WE
ARE GOING TO SEE A CONTINUED
TRAJECTORY THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> MOST HUMANS CANNOT FATHOM THE
DEPTHS OF DEPRAVITY THAT WOULD
ALLOW A YOUNG MAN TO SHOOT UP A
SCHOOL FILLED WITH CHILDREN.
DECLINING, NOT SO MASS SHOOTINGS
DECLINING, NOT SO MASS SHOOTING
SHOOTINGS.
>> AN EPIDEMIC IN SOME SENSE OF
NIHILISTIC HOPELESSNESS AMONG
NOT JUST YOUNG MEN, YOUNG PEOPLE
IN GENERAL.
>> THE CULTURAL REVOLUTION OF
THE 1960s BROUGHT WELCOME
CHANGE DISCRIMINATE --
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
MINORITIES, WOMEN AND GAYS.
TOXIC MASCULINITY.
>> BECAUSE MINORITIES AND WOMEN
ARE TAKING HIGHER POSITIONS AND
THEY HAVE MORE POWER.
WHITE MEN AND MEN IN GENERAL ARE
AFRAID THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR STRENGTH.
>> CRITICS ARGUE THE REVOLUTION
THROUGHOUT DEEPLY EMBEDDED
TRADITIONS OF CULTURE AND
CHILD-REARING.
>> IT'S A MOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
EXPRESS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
BE A MOTHER OR A PARENT WHO
GUIDES THE REARING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF A CHILD THAT IT
IS TO BE A RESEARCH SCIENTIST.
>> HE HAS BLOGGED ABOUT HIS
BELIEF THAT THE 60s REVOLUTION
REPLACED RIGOROUS SCHOLARSHIP
WITH A DUMBED DOWN CURRICULA.
>> WE HAVE GIVEN OURSELVES THE
PAST AND EDUCATING THEM, IN
REARING THEM.
>> OBSERVERS SAY SCHOOL HAVE TO
MANAGE MORE THAN THEY CAN
HANDLE.
>> THEY ARE CALLED UPON TO ACT
AS PARENTS TO THOSE PARENTS
WHOSE PARENTS AREN'T ACTING LIKE
PARENTS.
THEY ARE CALLED TO BE ALL OF
THESE THINGS.
>> THEY BOTH BELIEVE GUN-CONTROL
AND MENTAL HEALTH DEBATES CAN
WAIT.
A HIGHER PRIORITY IS TO FIX THE
CULTURE.
>> THEY NEED TO HAVE AT LEAST
ONE PERSON IN THEIR LIFE, A
STRAIGHT ARROW THAT FLIES TRUE
TO ORIENT THEMSELVES.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT, THEY
CAN BE EASILY LOST.
>> THAT FAT MAY BE RESONATING.
PETERSON'S NEW BOOK ROCKETED TO
NUMBER ONE ON AMAZON ON JANUARY